so much going on it's hard to keep up
with all of it stay cheerful in the face
of it
but here's a story that really makes you
think huge numbers large numbers of
illegal immigrants with coronavirus have
come across our border
illegally many of them are now in texas
now the white house has admitted
the government officials are not testing
these illegal aliens they have no right
to be here they apparently have covid
and no one seems to care
meanwhile you have to stay huddled in
your home with an obedience mask on
no one's doing anything about this until
now a former white house official
stephen miller spent most of his last
four years working immigration
questions is involved in a lawsuit that
would force the biden administration to
stop this
stop releasing coronavirus positive
illegal immigrants into
our country stephen miller as we said is
a former senior adviser to president
trump and president of
america first legal he joins us now
steve miller thanks so much
for coming on i'm i'm sorry that it fell
to you to do this where we're the
governors who should be on this but um
tell us thank you for doing it tell us
what you are doing
well i'm working with attorney general
ken paxton
who is a true patriot and we should all
be grateful to him to sue the biden
administration
on behalf of the people of texas for
flooding their state
with untested coveted infected illegal
immigrants
the fundamental question here tucker at
the heart of this whole
issue is whether american citizens are
second-class citizens in their own
country
you've talked about it on your show for
months now
americans have been forced to have their
businesses closed their schools closed
their lives disrupted their dreams
shattered
all because we're told we can't be close
to each other we can't be near each
other we can't
see our loved ones yet one group of
people one group alone
has been held out by the obama
administration as being subject
to none of these rules and yet these are
the people
who have no right to be here at all
illegal immigrants coming in violation
of law
i submit to you that if any business any
private association
any home in this country was run the way
that the border is being run it will be
shut down by the health department
in two seconds flat so we're going to
court and we're saying
the biden administration has to comply
with both federal law
which requires the detention of aliens
with communicable illnesses
as well as their own covet regulations
and return illegal immigrants back to
their home
country what would be the argument
against that
i mean how do they justify cracking down
really breaking the country using fear
about
kovid and then exempting people who are
foreign nationals here illegally from
those same restrictions like what's
their explanation for that
well i mean part of it could just be
that the political left and look ours is
a non-partisan organization
but that the political left in this
country believes that their social aims
and believes that their economic aims
are advanced by having massive numbers
of people
settle in the country who are not
invited and who have no right
to be here and it's frankly it's
humiliating for american citizens yes it
is it's debasing for american citizens
to be told you can't visit grandma and
grandpa but yet
thousands of people can be crammed
together in tractors and trailers and
vans and holding facilities
and then released to go into your
hospitals
to be taken care of with your tax
dollars and to have all of this happen
knowing that there is a regulation on
the books
it's called title 42 that says those
people have to go home
so the biden administration is breaking
the law every single day
to facilitate increased coveted
transmission
and our border communities especially in
texas are bearing the brunt of this
exactly i mean speaking for myself i'm
not mad at the immigrants they're just
doing what they're allowed to do it's
like i'm not really that mad at the blm
shakedown artists it's the people
of bedding them using them paying them
and allowing our border to become a
mockery of the law it's really
yeah those are the people this case will
decide tucker whether americans
in fact are still in charge of their own
country
man i hope you can prove that we are
stephen miller thank you appreciate it